[Music]
in the Dominican Republic
having kinky or coarse hair is perceived
as something that unclean and kept
something that is simply not beautiful
the salon really cares about the way
that curly hair is perceived in society
and we want to be a part of that change
fully in 2014 we were trying to go into
this bar and the bouncer said to my face
you can't come in because of your hair
this hair has done nothing to no one
this hair is part of who I am why should
I put this hair away I'm known as
mystery soz which means miss curls in
English and I am the owner of Miss
Teresa salon in the Dominican Republic
we offer all different types of services
specifically for naturally curly afro
textured hair
in 2010 I remember just straightening
the heck out of my hair as my curly hair
would grow in I would just touch my hair
feel the curl patterns and say like what
if all of my hair would feel this way
then that's when I decided that it was
time to look in the mirror and to love
myself fully
some of the things I would hear back
then is like did you forget your comb at
home
did you put your fingers on a socket I
mean all sorts of really mean things but
I had all these women to stop me and ask
me how to curl it how did I do it
where did I cut it there was this huge
thirst and hunger for space where women
would be validated and then that led to
this space that that I'm in now it's
been the most amazing activism I've done
all my life to think that with a brush a
pic or a comb I can empower someone
[Music]
it is alia emissary ever felt upon
personal orbital fatty liver Candela see
Elsa Waltrip eligible travel upon
recharge Oliphant a cappella chivalry
actually in those in dementia drop the
veins of you faulty and oncology voltage
enter pelvic apparently but we have a
notion not salary comparables irrelevant
Krishnamurti important a fish amo la
chica barbaric Ola la prima Barbara in
Milano edible very efficient Ellen come
on [ __ ] adeno sorry whatever
sorrowful music was tapa una volta chief
and civic appellee twist the most
importantly if actual apology laquanda
even aware named the lorry any ratio you
know Tonto the whistles attended by any
have such will appear
una volta is by we're not called
multiple times
alright more to the vessel is Barbie la
knowledge is the pewte we should model
the vessel not for material was on a
fallopian table be enabled eraser a
Brahmin boy which is appealing no
factory
Sally Malik
[Music]
Tabata Palo Alto Sanjay Miyagi Canyon
Alicia la tribuna a new Kindle each
other they make so you know my god turn
to go down line and then define true
Hotel Payoneer or chiffon Royalton to
Jean Todt anthony hi i'm anthony o of
atomic nice in Kenosha harnetiaux
Coppola so tiresome Julia for it
official I love you it's a moment ago
yeah [ __ ] out
um almost although y'all [ __ ] will be
faster that's how many straight guys
Tito
well you know alabaster trivia for your
fight on fact nobody allocates all y'all
are you lose yeah that's why little pipe
nipple doesn't sandy until it's at home
with a trophy oh you need your city your
vote relax into economy or eleventeen
yoga whatever fashion which he said as a
virgin
yes is a profile Yoshi you got
journal/nbc you know you should know
your favorite yeah Panama is on fasting
the jojoba cotton sheets na ma higher
utilization say hi Doritos esta la mama
de la matador Bishop Alvaro ha yosher la
da da da da da da
hi battleship in Seleucia almost like a
motivator in de my own father you're
jacking teeth
Panther Party that generally Bekah
Worster hadith sound maybe upon the new
Hydra Japan ago using the laws in fact
that's a PC of protein powder water
human intestine from part a year on
Nikita serum welcome bottle eternal
darkness san giovanni antonio de l'autre
modest iguana the only RTR woman to
others from physicians under the title
you gotta come into the room walk the
mercial you come into the room flower
womanly attention I will show you don't
tension without you the whole way yeah
what the ho title TG do is ask
[Music]
you get your hair done you can't be
touched
you're just you're on point for at least
48 hours the queer community needs a
safe space to get haircuts and that's
part of the reason why I'm here
my name is des Marshall I'm a barber I
work in Brooklyn New York
the barber shop I work at it's called
the gamesman it's kind of an institution
here in downtown Brooklyn the owner
Frank has been here for over 50 years
the clientele has been a lot of men who
working in the neighborhood it's a lot
of lawyers a lot of judges other types
of businessmen I kind of throw a wrench
in Soho that I mix it up a little bit my
clientele is mostly queer trans gender
non-conforming folks of color non folks
of color for the most part my clientele
is the LGBTQ community I think with
barbershops it's difficult as a woman to
walk in the can sometimes just feel like
a boys club it's nice to feel like you
can let your hair down or get it off I
think I'm building a bridge in different
ways can you be at 5:00 3:30 I got you
for queer folks the trans folks are
gender non-conforming folks hair is very
important you keep it really crisp or
more rounded got you but you need a
barber that you feel comfortable to talk
to about how you want to look what's
that vision that you have someone who
can execute it but also do it in a way
that they're not gonna be judging you
throughout the whole process
I get to spend my day with other queer
folks in a space that you know 20 years
ago we probably couldn't even walk
walked into you know I'm part of that
story now my clients are a part of that
story now we're part of the history of
this place
we're part of its legacy and that's it's
really cool
[Music]
the day I was going to sign my papers to
start working there were three thousand
inmates out there working iron and I was
like what did I get myself into here
my name is karma Shaheen I'm the career
technical and educator for cosmetology
at Valley State Prison for men when I
tell people that I work teaching
cosmetology at a men's prison a lot of
people are shocked by it they're
surprised they didn't even think that it
was available this program takes
approximately two years and they have to
have 1,600 hours completed in order to
take the State Board Exam there is a
waiting list to get into this class and
in order to get into this class an
inmate has to meet certain behavioral
and educational standards why you come
into my classroom you're going to treat
each other with respect and common
courtesy and there's no boundaries in
here which is gonna relax your facial
muscles and improve your face my name is
Juan Ruiz Walla I'm here at Valley State
Prison in Chowchilla California my
favorite part of the class is the skin
care part of it which includes like the
face shows eyebrows makeup I like to
just see my clients relax and get
comfortable with me with it's real
personal and being in prison they teach
you not to touch each other not to touch
staff it goes against the norm of what
people see about prison on TV you know
ex-gang members come in with tattoos on
their face all over their body is not
something that you see out there working
in a beauty salon it's putting a light
on a different side of the prison system
I do treat them as Jimmy's and I'm not
here to punish them I'm just here to
show them a skill that I have and it
happens to be in a prison I have more
empathy for people no because of doing
this type of work when they get their
license it's like I've gotten my license
first time all over again it's very
rewarding
[Music]